you know in Hollywood you'll see uh like
the rock he's all his stuff is on social
media Instagram you know he's doing this
he's doing that Under Armor you know the
zoa zoa drink that drink this drink big
on social media right some of the
Hollywood actors are big time on social
media some of them are zero on social
media right and I've always I've heard
different explanations on why not to do
you know here's why I'm not on social
here's why I don't want you to know what
I think about this here's why I don't
want you to know
from you being on the inside why aren't
some of these guys wanting to be on
social I mean Bradley Cooper's not on
social you got Dave Lewis not on social
a bunch of these guys not on social like
Leo's zero on social like so yeah I'm
very I'm very light on on social media
but mainly I don't really like looking
at myself you post once every tour yeah
I just don't like looking at myself at
all I mean I I really I I just over the
last few years have been able to watch
Entourage I just don't I don't know I'm
a private guy trust me my my girl always
like come on let's do like can we just
watch it do we have to do a video for
the Instagram
um I'm trying to
trying to get better I just I just don't
like it I just don't like it and unless
unless there's something to to promote
once in a while I'll go like I want to
post this picture but um yeah I'm just
I'm just kind of a private guy and I'm
more shy than anything else right I'm
not like trying to post pictures of
myself like you know I know it's crazy
that you're shy not shy but I mean I'm I
don't know private is more to work a shy
private you know kind of I'm sorry I
gotta go shirtless like hey what's up
guys
good way to lose followers
that's the other thing too like you just
want to you just want your number to
hold right like start posting and then
stuff drops you're like I knew I should
have done that you know I would I always
tell my girlfriend too I'm like Hey
listen don't because she's an actress
and she's she's got a good following I'm
like don't post pictures of me because
it's gonna hurt your numbers
[Applause]
she's like you that doesn't bother you
I'm like no I don't want to be on it
keep your numbers up there I will drag
you down and it's I will drag your
social media you think they want to look
pull up your Instagram page and see me
and and our baby like hey what's you
know so I'm like
um it's it's uh and then some people are
really good at it I mean you look at a
guy like Ashton Kutcher what he's done
and talk about being on the Forefront of
it no question yeah I I always tell the
story that says it's true way way back
in the day they did Nikki Hilton
and she was talking about this meeting
that she was going to and they were
pitching her and they wanted her to be
and it's involved and it was I'm like
well what is it well it's an app right
well you'll you'll say I'm like well you
say what well you'll say like oh me and
Pat
at the value came in and I go well
that's the stupidest idea I've ever
heard I wouldn't get involved in that
was Twitter so
it's a true story it's like that is the
worst idea I've ever heard in my entire
life it's going nowhere it's going into
the toilet
um so yeah that's my social media by the
way because I now that's just Ashton
Kutcher wasn't he at the beginning of
Twitter him and Larry King were
competing to see who gets to a million
first I don't know if you remember that
or right or is that what it was that's
what it was they were competing to get
to a million first yeah this was like I
never understood it's like all right
he's at the coffee bean okay
great like but you know I mean obviously
it it I missed the mark on that one
um
but yeah I mean and it evolves and you
know we've talked about this you know I
I always joke around I'm like everything
else is dead to me except tick tock
right that's it everybody else is out of
business as far as I'm concerned Tick
Tock is awesome now I'm not gonna be on
Tick Tock I'm not making any tick tocks
but I do love to scroll through some
tech talks
[Music]